hello and welcome to this video against
the trash must have light like Martin
Susan day I place the French surely not
exactly happy with this and because it's
not that's not been my focus of study
within one year for should be three see
if I the tix here this is the line I
know he can take on your form and it was
the wrong move water right that was the
wrong I played the wrong order okay
didn't take on any form but I think this
is an equalizer if i remember correctly
from back when i played this with black
creature
if i take on d5 you would probably take
with the knighthood I will not with the
Queen yeah why not why not and sure yeah
I can take with the Queen politics was
probably a bit questionable I would
rupee wanted
okay tween to h5 seeking 45-year know
what is not possible so let me just put
something on a half-open file when if I
think I can take Teddy five at least I
don't see this happening Bishop d7
doesn't work b6 doesn't work it's not so
easy from here okay six
we should have form maybe but Bishop e3
yep just just try to trade let's just
straight this that's it so bad it's this
most active p so let's trade this maybe
this hmm that looks wrong queenb alive
the queen is unprotected
does he have some f5 stuff that that's
just for a moment to think about it no
it works it works just f5 just quickly
f5 Queen take c5 here cannot take you
for so I think this is just a piece
should be just a piece
this position felt a little bit critical
anyway I mean not not the head behind of
course but it held a little bit of
somehow somebody couldn't develop all
that all that well but I'm kind of black
eyes I making it a post more than before
I resigned now he did resign yet it's
just a piece I'm just winning a piece
here or in this case winning this and he
has absolutely awful pieces left and so
what it wrong he what don't what what
what what what was wrong here I don't
know of the computer actually already
hates black here for some reason and it
gives I mean this is motif Queenie to
night before I knew from the from the
color opening actually I looked at the
caller some years ago and dead this was
good for white and the engine kind of
agree is it seems that black is and
slight issue inside trouble him what's
the play like this yeah this is how it
is played in the collar as well the
Queen doesn't have good squares yeah I
mean if it goes I'm sorry okay to h5
there is this and the Queen actually
doesn't have squares and we trap the
Queen iya on the Sun yeah look do you
want and the engine gives me five anyway
I was just thinking of I went upon that
he probably has compensation for it yeah
cakes look mate and compensation yeah
probably
that's what stock fish is giving line
maybe it's not quite enough as the
engine suggests but you can argue that
it could be better than this I know we
should be seven yeah with this is the
student work as we as we saw of it it's
some not very enjoyable position I guess
so here but okay here of the game just
continues not sure h3 is suggested by
stock fish I wonder does it age 3 is
actually kicking h2go is the idea maybe
try to win the Queen in black it doesn't
have easy moves here f5 as I suggested
this is something went wrong in the
opening black is not equally at all ok
guys thanks for watching